be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so we are continuing on with our
series on the boys and I dig do in this
series right like I big doing this I
feel like we should cover invincible
this is us getting a Netflix series that
next year I think we should do that like
that that would be pretty cool right
just like hammer out a whole bunch of
invincible videos I really wish they
would make a serious about irredeemable
that's a good one the one by Mark Waid
irredeemable sitter is on basically
Superman right he's not really called
Superman but it's essentially Superman
and it's like he saves the day it's like
its first outing I think and like he
saves the day and becomes corrupted by
like all the praise he gets and goes
crazy and like starts killing all the
superheroes it's really good like it's
is this it's like an amazing series
that's a thing like Marvel and DC have
some really good stuff but if you want
to get to like the really really amazing
stuff that's kind of off the beaten path
you got to go look at like creator own
comics like those are some of the
coolest things you're gonna see but in
any event this video on the boys we
focus on the origin of the superheroes
right like this timeline like like
Vaught Americans rise to power right so
close you guys who are basically
wondering how things got to this point
this is the one that we'll cover that
will cover all that stuff and what it
does is it winds back to World War two
right so it tells us that Von American
has been a company in the United States
for a long time like for a very long
time the issue with this is that bought
American was providing some really
shoddy weaponry the Von American like a
lot of companies out there that put
profits over quality of product was
basically cutting corners everywhere
that they were creating like really
shoddy products right like they were
creating it like playing something
called a grizzly which basically didn't
really work right like the end live
would give out if he went too fast the
guns wouldn't fire consistently and they
were implemented in World War two by
flawed American as a relatively new
product that could help win the war and
the result was that the US almost lost
the war because of it right I mean the
war in the Pacific was kind of the
turning Tod right the Battle of Midway
you know like island hopping things like
that like if we'd lost the Battle of
Midway Japan would have taken and we
would have lost like we would have lost
world war ii and so it's at or at least
the united states would have been
defeated during world war ii i will go
as far as to say we would have lost
entirely it's interesting with this
because what it shows is right off the
bat in the very beginnings vaughn
american didn't really care about the
quality of the product they made they
cared about the money they can make off
that product not only that it shows what
off the bat that what vaughn american
was looking for was to gain a foothold
and really gain like kind of dominance
over military contracts and so all this
is really told from the perspective of
the legend right basically
giving this information to Huey now
there is a kind of segment that goes on
here with regards to Billy butcher and a
home Lander but for the most part it's
it's really just kind of them having a
staredown and not a lot comes out of it
I mean but the meat and potatoes of this
is really the history of like vada
Merrick and how it all comes together
and so what you ended up getting here is
basically this idea the Von American got
some measure of a foothold not a big one
but got some measure of a foothold and
various military applications more or
less you know implementing their various
schemes of different things along those
lines but they got a huge hand in all of
that and the reason why is because they
knew all the right people right they
they had people in all the right places
and so while technically they should
never have had the opportunity to
implement a lot of these really really
crappy products they did because they
knew people who were not really
presidents or vice presidents in the
White House but they knew people in like
the Pentagon they knew people in
Congress and they could basically get
signatures on products that they were
making in order to implement them in the
military industrial complex following
that that went directly into Vietnam and
were their initial outing in world war
ii was kinda like okay so it didn't
really go the way we'd hoped but like
hey look we can make it work this time
all right everything will work
everything will be okay what you ended
up having was this scenario where a
portion of troops were like outnumbered
by like Viet Cong forces and the concern
was these guys are all gonna be taken
out but the response was what we're
using bought American weapons right
select you know we've got all these arms
and armament like there's no way these
guys can take us all out and the result
was that because yet again bought
American was creating really really
shoddy products these products failed
when they were needed and so what it
meant was that like a thousand soldiers
were all killed by they were they all
died in this massive confrontation that
went on between the u.s. and and Viet
Cong forces and so following this what
it led to you is for a time after
Vietnam and like the catastrophic
failure of Vaud American essentially
what happened was one American basically
just sort of vanished for like three
years they were gone and then suddenly
seemingly out of nowhere a meteor falls
from the sky it crashed lands at
Heartland America and there's a
super-powered person there right and so
following that you know this kid
basically aged up you know super fast it
was like the Superman story more or less
and so when this kids paraded out by
Vaught American he's everything people
want him to be right very Superman asked
for example there was a really really
good article that Mart or not really a
guitar well there was a good article by
Mark Waid had an interview in it and he
said one of the reasons why Superman has
always been so popular is because he's
everything to everyone he's a champion
of the oppressed in whatever era the
oppressed
currently in rhinitis he's always their
champion fighting on their behalf
incoming books more or less this guy
coming out here he was loved by everyone
right like he was a humble guy so he
didn't really present himself as an
imposing figure that somehow made men
feel emasculated right yeah because I
guess their confidence is tied directly
into how they perceive other men around
them he didn't really offend any like at
least when it came to women because of
the fact that he was slightly vulnerable
what it meant is they had romance they
were like well here's a vulnerable guy
and maybe I can sort of slowly chip away
and figure out what goes on with him and
figure out how he works you know and
that kind of a thing when it came to
people who were right-wing people who
were conservative they loved him because
he was powerful for people who were on
the left he was intelligent
right so they loved the fact that he was
a smart guy so it was basically one of
these things that was like everything to
everyone right like he was he was
literally what everybody wanted him to
be and the result was that he
immediately became exceedingly popular
following that there were six other
people who popped up and so what the
legend basically says is like as far as
the world was concerned these were just
super power beings who seemingly came
out of nowhere and thought America knew
who previously had less-than-stellar
success when it came to weapons
manufacturing is now having huge success
as a marketing company you know so it
was like people never really tied the
two together but the reality is that
bought American created these guys right
because bought American looked at their
ability to create guns and like tanks
and and arms of arm and things like that
and they couldn't do it in an in an
effective way they could generate a
profit margin right like they were
cutting too many corners and so they
said well let's get in genetic
engineering let's get into manipulating
genes now in terms of how that happens
you know we end up figuring that out
later on but they develop compound v and
the result was that developing compound
be allowed them to modify a human being
in the fetus and then in turn give birth
to a super-powered being and it's kind
of a funny thing because Huey asked the
question why did they only create seven
endless and the legend says well like
literally the injection you got from
Billy butcher that that enhanced your
abilities that gave you what you have
right now that's just one injection and
that cost nineteen billion dollars
imagine how much it made it cost to make
one of these guys and so that kind of
makes sense right if you're talking
about you know something that would cost
upwards to possibly even like a trillion
dollars in order to engineer a human
being from the timeit's of fetus to the
time that is born to develop superpowers
and then to make those superpowers
controllable so that he's not just
Cyclops right we're like home Lander
opens his eyes and everything in front
of them gets totally eradicated you know
in order to avoid something like that
you're talking about a massive feat in
genetic engineering it would be almost
unfeasible to be able to mass-produce
that on a huge scale at the same time
the genius behind that is it allows them
to do it in such a way to where the
number remains controllable it's much
easier to control seven superheroes than
it is 700 superheroes and so in response
to that came what were basically a
handful of different groups right you
ended up getting groups called the young
Americans you ended up getting payback
you ended up getting teenage kicks you
ended up getting g-men but the seven
were the only ones who really had any
major backing of vaud American behind
them the other ones who were there were
just the result of experimentation that
kind of a thing either accidents or
something along those lines but they
weren't really bred to be the absolute
best this seven were bred to be the best
right there the absolute best of what
any superhero could be with homeland or
being the best of death right so he's
the best version of a character was kind
of cool about this whole thing is you
get a guy named Johann Vogel bomb he's
nothing is how you pronounce it and it's
very very Captain America right if those
are guys who were familiar with Captain
America's history
Abraham Erskine was a guy who was
discovered to basically create a
super-soldier serum he was taken from
Germany by by Nick Fury in the Howling
Commandos
brought to the United States and he
became part of project rebirth this
basically basically this same process
happens here and so far that that Johann
Vogel bomb did not want to create super
soldiers for the Germans and so he was
basically brought to the United States
it started creating compound V for von
American and steth the crazy thing about
this is he didn't really know what the
intention of von American was for the
most part it seemed like they intended
to keep him in the dark did it really
seem that they didn't really intended to
tell him what the extensive with the
extensive nature of it was the issue
with this is that once Vogel bomb began
to realize that the purpose behind von
American creating superhumans basically
was was a nefarious and so far that it
wasn't really for the purpose of
protecting the world so much as like
acquiring profit and really for like
nefarious means he ended up basically
you know offered himself more or less
didn't really want to be boxed into a
corner or anything but then that gets
him to the role of the legend himself
and this gets him the role of comic
books and it's the absolute smartest
thing that possibly could have been done
by von American and the reason why is
because in any given particular
circumstance not just the modern day but
over the course of the history of
humanity the nature of people is that
people will believe what they want to
believe that people wanted to believe
that superheroes were good guys people
wanted to believe that superheroes were
there
protectin and so an order from one
American to feed the people what they
wanted to believe they created comic
books and the entire basis behind these
comic book stories was to basically feed
people the narrative they've wanted to
hear now this is pretty bad like it's a
really crappy thing to do and the reason
why is because for the most part the
American people can't really be trusted
when it comes to things like the average
person can't really be trusted with
things especially if what they want to
believe flies in the face of what's good
for them and so because of that like if
people say like whoa we really want to
destroy the country using nuclear bombs
well that's not beneficial for society
so you can't like you can't put that
kind of trust in the hands of people you
take that trust away from them and say
what you want will lead to the
destruction of society so we're taking
that away from you right because you're
an idiot basically you know like you
wanted to do you want to do chef
yourself into your own oblivion
we can't trust you with that you know
and so you can't always put trust in the
hands of the people but when you look at
this and you say okay what you have here
is them feeding the narrative that
heroes are good guys no wonder the world
turned out the way that it did because
what you had is you had a scenario where
you had a company a weapons
manufacturing company that was producing
biological weapons in the form of
superheroes and then people refusing to
believe that there could have been a
nefarious purpose there or even doing
any investigation automatically assume
they're here to help us and so because
they wanted to assume that they wanted
to believe that and so in turn Vaughn
American fed them what they wanted to
believe and then really just kind of
people stuck their head in the sand and
everything just sort of ended up where
it is right now but it really is
intriguing there because it's one half
the fault of people and then the other
half the fault of a company at the end
of the day when it comes down to life
who really bears responsibility there
who do you point the finger out at the
end of the day I would point a finger at
the people right I would say is the
people's fault they could have done
their own investigation they could have
done any number of things they could
have found the facts if they wanted to
because the facts were there it's
interesting because but what the legend
would do is comb through all these
different stories and what he would do
is he would take a scenario that
happened in the real world and then he
would change the outcome of that
scenario to reflect what people wanted
to see and so there's there's this one
situation worse like okay he goes out to
the middle of nowhere out in the
mountains sent some states somewhere you
know he has a fighting against some some
villain and we're like he basically just
like flies through the villain and like
punches a hole through that guy and just
kills them you know beheads him in the
most gruesome way the comic book story
plays out much differently all well
we're fighting yet again you know and
and so on you know you can't defeat me
this time and it takes what's basically
a careless super
hero who has no real regard for the
lives of the people who he's essentially
facing off against and paints him as a
guy who's a good guy he's fighting the
good fight you know all that kind of
some very patriotic you know in in that
sense and it's interesting the way that
is depicted because that's just not
really the way the superheroes function
but it's the way they're depicted to
function so it's what people assume to
be true right so the question after that
was Avadh American has essentially
engineered superheroes and his using him
as a means to attain power then the
question becomes what's the next step
how do you get von American from a
company this engineering superheroes to
a company that has a foothold it has
control in the United States and so what
they end up doing is they end up
basically getting a former businessman
to attain the position of the Vice
President of the United States to work
on their behalf the problem with this is
that what Von American is doing has not
gone unnoticed and that's well that's
why I said you know am i arguing with
two people you could point the finger
the people who say it's your fault
because you allowed this to happen by
just ignoring the reality of the
situation on believing what you want to
believe will you have other companies
other corporations looking at this and
saying okay so like vaad american is
basically engineering superheroes bought
american is creating superheroes and
then using that as a means to basically
say hey look we can use this to
safeguard the United States just give us
weapons contracts US government
everything will be okay that other
companies were trying to fight against
them to keep that from happening now
other companies weren't doing this
because it was the right thing to do
other companies were doing this because
they solve on American as a challenge to
their rule why do you need tanks and why
do you need guns and why do you need
bullets and things like that
if all you have to do is send home
Lander in and instill such an extreme
amount of fear in the enemy that they'll
be terrified to attack the United States
or any property that belongs to the
United States lest homeland or go in
kill all the soldiers and all their
families right so if you could use that
as a weapon against the enemy you don't
need to send in US forces and so if
you're Lockheed Martin and your entire
platform is is based on the on the
process of like creating missiles we're
creating this or creating that or
something along those lines you know or
your Boeing and you create like military
craft you know military planes that go
out and do things I don't know if the
law really does that you know if you're
one of those guys who are weapons
manufacturers you're literally like okay
so our survival is at risk here and so
fighting for survival what they did is
they ended up getting like the President
of the United States elected like over
this period of time over the short
period of time because of this mad race
to ensure survival in the
military-industrial complex
companies were dumping money into
Congress it reached the point where like
2/3 of Congress and the president and
the vice-president were bought and paid
for by companies right slowly America is
exceedingly corrupt at this point in
time when the story takes place and so
as a result so that you basically had
vicked the veep who was working on
behalf of on American albeit the guy was
an idiot and basically just took orders
then you have the President of the
United States working on behalf of
everybody else in the
military-industrial complex and that's
the reason why so long as the president
is an office nothing from flawed
American will get past in terms of
weapons weapons contracts but the
president won't let it happen any bill
presented by Congress will basically be
vetoed by the president and where you
could look at that you could say okay
but like a two-thirds majority vote
could overrule the presidential veto
Congress is split right I mean like half
belongs to all these companies and half
the long stuff bought American you know
and that's just two thirds of Congress
not even the other third there's no real
way to ensure a presidential veto is
overturned in Congress itself and so as
a result of that there's this this
massive moment that comes along right
you know we're fought Americans kind of
in a position where they have the vice
president there and they say okay fine
then let's use the court of public
opinion let's use public with the public
opinion to force the president's hand
right like listen you know let's use
that as a means to control him right
because at the end of the day Congress
exists to ensure its position right like
any any congressman congresswoman or any
senator basically serves the purpose of
trying to secure reelection
it's what they do is that's their goal
and so as a result of that if in the
face of public opinion the public says
if you do not impeach the sitting
president then in turn we're gonna kick
you out of office Congress is going to
impeach the sitting president if they
believe there's a credible threat to
losing their position if they don't
impeach the president then they're
basically gonna be outed and so in order
to try to force the president's hand to
either step down or force Congress to
impeach him what they end up doing is
crafting public opinion in such a way so
that when 9/11 basically goes down in
this comic it doesn't go down exactly
the same way it did here here in the
states instead the way things happen is
like you know hijackers are taking one
of the planes they were supposed to
crash it into one of the towers Jets
were sent in to respond and to take
these passenger liners down and then out
of nowhere they were told stand down
like back down and so the result of this
is that seemingly under the direction of
the Vice President which begs the
question what was the president doing
under the direction of the vice
president you end up having all these
fighter jets were stand down and the
seven respond the issue
this is a seven had no idea what they
were doing these guys are trained and
that's that's the biggest issue here
they don't go through like hostage
rescue training they don't know how to
talk to people now they don't know any
of that stuff
they're people who were basically
engineered to have superpowers and then
like seemingly overnight they were
elevated to what a lot of people praise
is like God status based me that's one
of the things that said a year is when
God American goes as far as to pull the
American people in to say would you
support electing like homeland to the
position of president people were like
no because it'd be like electing Jesus
to the office of the presidency is just
too much power in the hands of a person
who's too powerful what stops him from
never giving that power up you know so
because of that people were just kind of
like okay when the seven fly in here and
the seven get in there it's a total show
and that's exactly what it is like they
get it they have no clue what they're
doing right like they're in there like
okay so we're gonna open the doors and
we're gonna and we're gonna take out
these hostages you know it's some I mean
at this point probably not 30,000 feet
probably something more like you know 15
20 thousand feet the air they rip open
one of the doors of the airplane some
kids yanked out like people are being
sucked out left and right they get in
there everything goes to pop but instead
of it just being Queen Maeve and being a
being home Lander you've also got like
Marathon Man you've got a handful of
people here you've got Lamplighter these
are kind of popping off that things are
going nuts and so when they get in there
like home Lander totally overwhelmed by
like all the screaming and the crying
and the panicking sort of loses his mind
he gets in there he takes out some of
the terrorists guys and then destroys
the the flight system in the process he
looks at Queen may he's like I thought
you had a plan she's like well no I
thought you had a plan like nobody
really knows what anybody's supposed to
do none of this was planned out and so
with the planes essentially in a
position to where it's gonna go crashing
down the question is like are you going
to save them and the responses there's
nothing we can do like home Landers just
like forget about like whatever who
cares it's a total disregard he's like
whatever man let's just go like Marathon
Man launches our lashes on to him he's
basically a stand-in for the flash
Marathon Man grabs a man is up you know
kind of flying with him then it's like
look dude the planes gonna hit the city
and so then you end up having like like
home Lander who flies into the plane
winds up like breaking it in half and
the plane crashes into the Brooklyn
dredging takes out the Brooklyn Bridge
Marathon Man is killed in the process
and it's just like like the whole thing
is just a total cluster because what you
ended up having is you have these guys
who are totally untrained they don't
know how to handle these things right
there's a reason why specialized teams
are trained in such a way to where they
basically go through and they they
practice routines like this over and
over and over again so that when things
like this happen they can respond
accordingly this is like grabbing a
handful of cops off the street and then
just throwing him into a situation of
course they're not gonna know what to do
like of course I'm not gonna know how to
handle it because they have been trained
for and so in the aftermath of this
there were two things that went down one
you had the American people who were mad
that an attack happened on their soil
you had the American people who were
asking questions like how could this
attack have happened and then in turn
you had the American people angry
wanting like somebody to pay for it the
issue with this is that if the American
people had learned that one the
government was asleep at the wheel which
led to the attack happen in the first
place and to that the plane crashing
into the Brooklyn Bridge was the result
of the sevens screwing up the American
people would have turned on the
government and vaughan American and so
as a result of that working in tandem
winded up happening is basically a
finger was pointed to Pakistan the
government said well those are the ones
to blame let's go get them and they took
the American people's eyes off of them
the American people bought into it hook
line and sinker and basically looked
directly at Pakistan and said let's go
get him and then at the same time bought
American used victory comics use their
coming book arm as a means to sweep it
all under the rug and to say well the
seven did everything they could there's
nothing they could have done here they
they did their best by God they fought
the good fight and that's and that's
basically oh that's that's really what
happened here and the American people
bought into it as well
and so as a result of that seemingly a
lot of hands came out squeaky clean that
otherwise should not have here and so
following that what you ended up getting
into was basically the launch of the
boys the the creation of the boys
organization now what the legend
basically tells Huey is that the
formation of the boys originally came by
a guy named Greg Dean Mallory and Greg
Dean Mallory fought during World War two
and had a vendetta against everything
that was going on with the idea of the
superheroes are so on and so forth but
the issue with this was that he
initially walked away with the first
iteration of the boys and the reason why
is because he was a guy who would dig up
information and look for weaknesses when
it came to the boys making their move
there were a lot more heavy-handed like
they were just they would strike hard
and fast well the problem with this is
that if you strike in that way you're
gonna get an equal response to that and
so as a result with home Lander and then
realizing that they're being screwed
around with that somebody's messing with
them and then ultimately routing it back
to Greg Dean Mallory Lamplighter goes
through and kills Greg D Mallory's
granddaughter's and so as a response to
that because the battle came so close to
Holmes
Mallory backed off Mallory basically
walked away from the boys after
experiencing this kind of crushing
sensation the way that he did and the
boys essentially seem to have disbanded
or at the very least taken less of a
heavy-handed
and that's the reason why now when Billy
butcher launches his missions he doesn't
do it so heavy handedly he doesn't go in
guns blazing launching this full-on
attack against all the various
characters instead this espionage
subterfuge is using a very secretive
hand to basically say hey look like just
so you know we're watching you and we're
making moves against you but we're not
doing it in such a heavy-handed way it's
grabbing information that's really what
what's what really the the big thing
that goes on with the boys of the moment
that's the reason why homeland her and
company don't just show up and kill them
all is because they're safeguards in
place with all the information the boys
have gathered if they all basically die
that information would be let out to the
media and the whole world would really
see what that a seminar actually like in
terms of video footage and all that kind
of stuff and no longer what the American
people be able to kind of just ignore
the reality of the situation they would
have to take their head out of the sand
and then look at look around and realize
okay so yeah things aren't really what
we thought they were you know it's
essentially how things would go down at
the same time if the boys made a hard
move against the against the seven the
seven would take him out we basically
have an armistice right we've we've got
a ceasefire all being grudgingly but
we've got a ceasefire going on neither
one of us are launching that part of an
attack against the other and so what
they ended up doing in order to kind of
set things in stone in order to sort of
keep things kind of locked up a sort of
of treaty was signed more or less in the
form of like a sacrifice in the form of
a character that was going to be
executed and that's the reason why I
applied if loading guys who've been
following this that's why the
Lamplighter went missing is because the
official story wasn't we don't know
where Lamplighter is lamplighters taking
a break essentially and Lamplighter is
taking a break from being part of the
7ah meet our new members starlight when
the reality was Lamplighter was
sacrificed you know it was basically one
of these things where the boys were like
if you do not give us somebody we're
dumping everything out there and so in
response this is seven said okay fine
Lamplighter is the one that killed the
the granddaughters of Greg D Mallory you
guys get to have Lamplighter and
Lamplighter was killed by the boys and
that was kind of the the ceasefire there
was basically agreed upon between the
two groups because the bloodshed was so
extreme and that was the reality but
both groups had so much to loot they had
so much to lose here that it was kind of
like okay let's create a ceasefire let's
kind of keep things you know sort of on
the back burner at the moment and so
that's one of the one of the questions
that's asked here by by Huey is well
then what's your involvement in all this
you know like what led you to become the
person that you are right now why are
you divulging all this and what we end
up learning is that that basically
legend has a vendetta against fought
American the stims all the way back to
the Vietnam War that you lost a son
there that he lost a son dear like
they're malfunctioning weapons and there
to cut corners and so on and so forth
and he's always held a held a vendetta
against them once they started
manufacturing superheroes and he started
realizing how far down the rabbit hole
it went when he was working with the
company he was basically stockpiling
information once everything came to a
head and it was like okay so now they're
trading superheroes and I'm crafting the
narrative for these superheroes you know
working for this company victory comics
so on and so forth it was stockpiling
information to the side and using that
information and passing it to the boys
later on which is how he became involved
in their in their organization in the
first place it's actually really
interesting and it's really really
intriguing here and so because we've
covered so much in the short amount of
time I'm gonna cover the cover the other
half of this in next week's video write
everything that was going on with
regards to starlight in and so on and so
forth this is a lot of origin story to
cover it's certainly one of the most
packed stories the Garth Ennis did when
it came to the boys
dumping like a ton of information in
there right so we're gonna tack this on
we're gonna do the other half in the
video next week if you guys are new here
to comments explain it make sure you
guys are the sub button to become part
of the Rob port if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]